on vient de le dire qui minent son ya
donc créé la première dynastie
communiste au monde son fils kim jong-il
à 50 ans n'est jamais sorti de son pays
et certains redoutent qu'il soit tenté
pour préserver son pouvoir par une sorte
de fuite en avant en relançant le
chantage nucléaire mis en place par son
père olivier dernière derrière son papa
on le voyait souvent applaudir des deux
mains kim junior
on va sans doute bientôt le voir à
l'oeuvre il dirigeait déjà le parti
l'armée sans pour autant faire
l'unanimité
c'est bien pour ça qu'une certaine
inquiétude règne depuis ce matin en
corée du nord et la gorge passer au tout
est fermé tout était espéré c'est
certainement dans un mois dans deux mois
on va avoir un peu plus clair mais c'est
un mois aux deux mois ou trois mois
ce sera extrêmement important
l'enseignement au rapport entre le nord
et le sud mais aussi pour le monde
entier
il y a trois semaines à peine jimmy
carter salué tout sourire le président
nord-coréen
une image qui n'était pas passée
inaperçue aux états unis carter chargé
d'obtenir un gel permanent du programme
nucléaire nord-coréen
en échange de quoi il y aurait
reconnaissance diplomatique et
assistance économique il ya eu lettre
les purges par laquelle il a éliminé
physiquement tous ses adversaires
politiques et tout le régime qu'il a
créée la coupe du monde extérieur qui a
freiné complètement le développement du
pays et qui est qu'elle chez essayer de
sauver son régime par tous les moyens y
compris donc actuellement par le
chantage nucléaire
le chantage appartient peut-être au
passé 12 informations confirment un
changement d'attitude
le sommet prévu pour le 25 juillet
prochain entre les deux corées est
confirmée et puis américains et coréens
du nord vont poursuivre leurs
discussions sur le nucléaire à genève
kim jong il n'est peut être pas le fils
à papa